it's my final show today and i have been
reminded of all the incredible times
we've shared together
and these don't even include the fun
we've had together off-screen because
trust me we've had some great times
but now um i just want to take a few
minutes to let each of you know
how much you mean to me um ladies you
know
we've had time to kind of talk to each
other and process
a bit um which i'm so happy about
because right now i'd be curled up in a
ball in this chair
probably if we didn't have that time but
i have said it once i've said i'll say
it again i've said it a few times that
i truly genuinely for real
love you i love you mrs o i love you
cheryl and carrie ann
i know you're watching i love you um i
have been
so lucky and so grateful
to be a part of this show i've learned
from
each of you ladies i've gotten some
something from you
all whether that's being more authentic
mrs o
or whether that is like knowing who you
are and standing your ground cheryl
and or whether that is opening up your
soul
carrie anne i have gotten so much from
all of you
and you guys have been beyond
supportive i was so scared to call you
and tell you that i was leaving because
i was like
i don't wanna like i don't want to leave
it's the hardest thing it's a bit it's
very bittersweet
and i was actually really worried to
talk to you and the
first thing that happened was that you
all were like
girl we're happy for you you better go
do you you got stuff to do you better go
and i was like
oh my god it was the most beautiful
feeling to feel
supported and loved and that same thing
goes for
all the people everybody watching this
all the people you can't see
that bring this show together everyone
from the top
from everyone who does things in the
offices that does things on set who do
everyone that helps us bring this
amazing show to you behind the crap the
camera
everything every department i've gotten
so many beautiful messages
i've gotten nothing but support and i've
always only
felt love and support every time i've
come to set
um i am grateful i will be forever
grateful and like i said this is not
goodbye this is i'll see you later
and yeah thank you
you